all right one more Elon Musk story and
that the Elon Musk stuff is just getting
worse and worse and worse Elon Musk
tweeted
um over the weekend
oh God he tweeted quote my pronouns are
prosecute slash fouchy
this is basically two different things
one
it's ridiculing and making fun of gender
pronouns which is very very big right
now on the right one of the uh areas
that most excites and titillates the
right at this point in time is being
anti-trans anti-trans is just really big
on the right at this point in time so
Elon Musk is sort of stoking that and
also Elon Musk is stoking more violence
against Dr fauci and his wife and his
family Dr fauci needing Securities a
doctor he needs security because of the
amount of ire and targeting that has
been done of Dr fauci so stoking unrest
um
additionally by the way that tweet for
Milan musk got a million likes on
Twitter so for all of the arguments that
Twitter is a left-wing Cesspool uh the
right wing stuff coming from people like
Elon Musk and others getting a lot of
likes a lot a lot of likes another
aspect to the crazy weekend from Elon
Musk is the following is reported by the
street
Elon Musk threatens Twitter 2.0
employees
um the billionaire social media revamp
efforts are widely covered in the Press
Elon Musk likes to control the narrative
um he has fired a whole bunch of
different people and now he is
threatening leakers people who leak
information with lawsuits that is what
this article is about and I encourage
you to check it out Elon Musk saying
Twitter will immediately seek damages
Twitter will immediately seek damages
Elon Musk is threatening to sue Twitter
employees who leak confidential
information to the Press he's asking
staffers to sign a pledge indicating
they've understood the letter by the way
the how Wild is it that the letter
threatening people about leaking has
leaked
as evidenced by the many detailed leaks
of confidential Twitter information a
few people at our company continue to
act in a manner contrary to the
company's interests and in violation of
their NDA this will be said only once if
you clearly and deliberately violate the
NDA that you signed when you joined you
accept liability to the full extent of
the law and Twitter will immediately
seek damages so it is more and more and
more of this exact same stuff that we
started seeing before Elon Musk even
purchased Twitter of course those on the
right including like on Fox news they
find it all hilarious here's Dagan
McDowell
commenting on the the humor of prosecute
fauci but John Brennan was at it again
over the weekend you know Elon Musk was
going after fauci and uh you know his
regular hilarious way yes prosecute
fauci is just really really funny a
doctor
with Decades of service
who is trying to deal with or has had
been trying to deal with a pandemic a
global pandemic
he needs to be targeted in Elon musk's
humorous way these folks are very
dangerous and at this point it's really
clear that what Elon Musk wants to do
is to promulgate and perpetuate
right-wing disinformation and the
Shilling for that type of uh uh that
type of content on Twitter what his
underlying motivation is I don't really
know and it's speculative is it that he
genuinely has political views that he
believes are best served by fomenting
right-wing disinformation on Twitter
maybe maybe that's what it is is there
some personal financial angle that he
believes would be served by turning
Twitter into some kind of right-wing
disinformation chamber maybe that's the
case uh could it be that he is working
in concert with I don't even know who
and that all together they've decided
let's destroy Twitter from the ends I
don't believe we know yet I believe it's
premature to explain exactly what it is
that is motivating all of this but it is
getting very very bad and I don't
believe it's going to turn around
anytime soon we'll have all of these
clips on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpackman show on Instagram
before you go if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the subscribe subscribe button
below or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description